before we get into the video we have a
giveaway thanks to the awesome community
team at Ubisoft Australia I have a
division agent watch to give away these
are actually pretty cool loads really
surprised by the quality there's a
decent amount of weight behind these if
you are interested in joining the
competition you just have to visit the
link below I have it in the description
too and answer one question what is my
son's name
no vents in the comments but the answer
can be found in my last video don't
worry if you don't win this one I have a
few more to give away at a later date
right after Black Friday people began
getting sick the initial symptoms were
mild so doctors and medical staff
assumed it to be a more serious version
of the flu but when people around the
world started dying
they started studying the virus and
realized it was smallpox to combat this
they're released smallpox taxi this
should have been the answer but they
quickly found that this had little to no
effect in New York City the authority to
maintain this epidemic was given to the
local hospitals with the New York Police
Department as the force to maintain
order very quickly it became apparent
that this was too big a task for the
hospitals in NYPD large numbers of
people were being infected and order
within the city was being lost the
governor of New York called in the
National Guard to assist with the
containment efforts sending the army to
Manhattan is it that bad the National
Guard baby I'll tell you what I know
what's happening ok ok very scary Eugene
you just hold tight stay inside
[Applause]
eventually the sickness and lack of
resources led to the NYPD and National
Guard members to start to dwindle it was
decided that they would combine to work
as a single unit from then on they were
known as the Joint Task Force
the Joint Task Force Ward GTF is a
collaboration between the police
National Guard firefighters and civil
volunteers working in tandem with the
catastrophic emergency response agency
the goal is to stop the spread of the
virus and maintain order within New York
City these were real people plucked from
the normal day jobs to assist in
something much bigger than what they
were ever trained for captain Roy
Benitez is a former New York City police
officer and the leader of the Joint Task
Force
Benitez was a narcotics officer for
eight years and his father was a police
officer before he is a very
black-and-white view on life the right
way and the wrong way he isn't afraid to
do the right thing regardless of who he
upsets along the way an attribute that
is likely held him back in his career he
is stubborn and could teach classes on
how to hold a grudge but Benitez is a
force to be reckoned with
he is relentless when it comes to
solving a case and will go above and
beyond the call of duty
Benitez lost his wife to the virus early
on in the outbreak before the dollar
flew his commitment to the force and
their inability to have children mean
that there was a rift there and they
were on the verge of separation because
of this Benitez carries a lot of guilt
that he struggles to deal with the JTF
solution was simple quarantine all known
infected individuals in the center of
the city to keep them away from healthy
civilians so they could easily be
treated and to stop the spread I think
you achieve with it the lockdown is a
necessary precaution to control the
situation we have enough to handle as it
is what are you doing most people just
want to leave the city to meet with
their family
we will reevaluate the relocation plan
at some point but for now the lockdown
holds now miss I've got work to do here
you really should stop looking for
trouble and make sure your own family is
safe on occasion the JTF were assisted
by private military contractors who were
initially hired to protect corporate
assets one of these contractors was the
last man battalion
unfortunately the JTF was simply not
prepared for what would come their lack
of numbers equipment and training mean
that the situation quickly got further
out of hand
the last man battalion grew frustrated
with the leadership and direction of the
JTF and cut ties stating that a more
aggressive and brutal stance was
required to get results and when the JTF
officials questioned them on this they
were executed on top of this the guards
at Rikers prison
understaffed we're overpowered and the
prisoners escaped on to the mainland
they placed a target on the JTF as they
were the reason they were all there in
the first place jtf numbers were
dropping rapidly they were shot on sight
by the LMP and were being hunted down
for sport by the Rikers another hostile
faction called the cleanest were
starting to take control of one side of
the city and uprisings of rioters were
banding together to take advantage of
the now lawless land it was around this
time that the division agents were
activated they were sent in to assist
the JTF with their mission but it was
too late the JTF was forced to abandon
the quarantine zone this action created
a rift between the government and the
first wave of division agents following
this the division agents dropped
communications and disappeared into the
dark zone at this point the JTF Familia
minor hindrance to the growing hostile
presence in New York City they were
undermanned and outgunned as unrest and
failing morale decimated their ranks the
JTF lost control of New York
leaving the city to turn into a lawless
deathtrap for its citizens
unable to effectively coordinate and
manage the response the JT have now puts
their hope in the members of the second
way of division agents to lead the way
the scattered JT of troops are ready to
assist to the division agents whenever
possible most have been placed to
protect the base of operations in Camp
Hudson while a few of them are in charge
of gathering information and
reconnaissance and sending this data to
the division the JTF also mans various
checkpoints throughout the city and
sends out patrols wherever possible
their ranks were boosted when the
division agents receive Roy Benitez from
the Lincoln Tunnel checkpoint that was
under siege by the rioters but the JTF
would never regain this strength to the
point without be competitive against the
now well-established hostile factions
the future of this group was now better
suited as a support role to the second
wave division agents
fast forward seven months the most
organized hostile factions in New York
now been dealt to in order was starting
to be restored the division agents have
done their job and can now hand the city
back to the joint task force but the JTF
story doesn't finish here based on the
very small amount of information we've
seen so far in the division to one of
the enemy factions the true sons is led
by a former JT of officer what happened
was the corruption within the ranks were
they unhappy with how things were
handled how many others have changed
sites
maybe it's ramus perhaps he was left
motion Elise card after we left him on
the Lexington roof all those times
whatever the reason that's hard to fear
this new faction based on what we know
of the JTF
at the end of the division one's story
but we need to remember we won't be
fighting the JTF as such will be
fighting paramilitary warlords being led
by the JTF and if there is one thing
that the JTF did well was reconnaissance
and giving us all the information we
needed to combat the hostile factions
this faction is going to know all about
the division our strengths our
weaknesses I wouldn't write them off
just yet
that's it for my quick video on the JTF
I actually wasn't going to cover these
guys but it's come up a number of times
in the comments over the last few videos
so keep the suggestions coming in I'll
get to them eventually you may have
noticed the images and graphics have
changed a bit in this one I'm getting a
bit sick of using the same old cutscenes
over and over so I'm trying out a few
other options to show the story let me
know you think before I go I must thank
a few of the many amazing people for
being able to go the extra mile for
supporting the channel in particular
Devereux you're a legend
I can't thank you enough thank you
everyone for the support on the last
video the comments were truly motivating
I look forward to doing this as long as
I can Cheers
[Music]